they say that humans are a dog's best
friend and I think that's true here's my
human he just looks so cute when he
sleeps sometimes I wonder what he dreams
about we've got a pretty good thing
going for example he just bought me a
stationary car window for my birthday
which was pretty cool no pun intended
we may not look it but we're pretty
healthy we need a balanced diet and we
do workout I take him on smell tours of
the neighborhood and he scratches that
area that makes me lose control of my
body hey Gus
what do you think about that but
sometimes I just worry that he could use
a little extra company here's the
problem humans over complicate
everything
case in point and yes tonight is very
important to me okay I haven't had a
date in a very long time lab lab lab lab
lab he overthinks it you chase each
other around and then you lick each
other's faces and it's on simple but no
instead he spends hours destroying
random things he found in the garden to
present to his date maybe to prove he's
a hunter I don't know none of that stuff
runs away and it's show time
hey welcome come on touch noses no oh
and they shake it's not even an
impressive trick by the way now here's
the part that kills me they're hungry
there's food in front of them and they
just blab for hours and then when they
do eat they play this weird game of food
golf from these complicated sticks
navigating weeds into their mouth holes
what do you like to do on the weekends
uh-oh don't say it don't say it taxes oh
you said it
Millie that's
just do taxes like all the time all
right oh my god guys I love you oh yes
it's true part of being a best friend
doesn't mean you have to run
interference when it's needed
he's so cool yeah yeah he's a good dog
well in any case if anyone out there
wants a dinner date with me I keep it
simple set the table fill your plates
with healthy delicious food and then we
eat we can save the talking for when
we're full
Wow